mm-hmm
hey welcome to the 13 o'clock podcast
and we're back again for our third
episode
and today we're doing we're talking
about like uh two different subjects
but they both have a common theme we
thought we would do kind of a
weird memory kind of theme what you got
for me
well the first topic actually was uh the
idea of a
facebook friend of ours who suggested
that we do it and i had never heard of
it but apparently it's a big thing
uh called the mandela effect um
like i said i had never heard of it but
when i looked it up i guess it was a big
thing on the internet and everyone's
talking about it there's websites and
whatever
and what's the other one uh the other
one is gonna be we're talking about like
a weird
reincarnation kind of case or what could
possibly be a reincarnation case
all right you uh you lay it on me and
i'll just sit back here and vape
and throw my tooth heads okay in
tired tonight that's oh well we you know
all right now let's go now just
joke around go ahead well okay if uh for
those of you who don't know the mandela
effect is actually it's not just a case
of
misremembering something which we all do
it's actually a case of
where a whole bunch of people remember
something incorrectly in the same exact
way
for example probably one of the most
common ones
has to do with the children's book and
cartoon the berenstain bears
now many many many people insist
that it's the berenstein bears or at
least it was when they were growing up
um i can't really speak to this because
i always remember it being berenstain
so all you people that remember being
berenstein i don't know what your
problem is
well hold on hold on explain this
explain this
effect what i mean what are they saying
this is some kind of quantum anomaly are
they saying that the ch
the past is changing well there are some
different
paranormal theories there are also some
skeptical theories which we will get
into
the paranormal theories basically boil
down to
uh one these people that remember it
quote unquote incorrectly are coming
from a different
time stream or a different dimension
uh the second one is that someone is
changing the past for whatever reason
okay even though it always seems to be
minor things changing the past
yeah okay um or erasing the past and
replacing it with something else
or that there's a glitch in the matrix
as the saying goes
okay that we all live like in a holodeck
kind of universe well what other
examples did
do they give to support this that you
you know i mean you have to have more
than one example yeah you can't just be
about bears
right well i was going to say the
actually the phrase
the name mandela effect was coined by a
quote-unquote paranormal consultant
named fiona broome
all right and she first coined it
because she was at a convention
and she was talking about to someone
about um
nelson mandela like you do and she
thought that he had died in prison in
the 1980s
and this other person said he also
believed
that nelson mandela had died in prison
in the 1980s now nelson mandela
did not die until 2013. okay he was out
of prison for a very long time
but apparently when she posted about it
on her blog or whatever
a [ __ ] ton of people wrote to her and
said oh my god i also thought nelson
mandela died in prison in the 1980s
so and as this mandela effect thing
kind of got into the public
consciousness
a lot of other people started coming
forward remembering things like the
berenstain bear thing
um there's like a lot of movie ones too
like misremembered movie quotes and
stuff like that
give me some examples what the movie
quotes or just movie the movie stuff
um well you know some of these are kind
of not that big a deal like a lot of
people remember
you know obviously the famous line from
star wars being luke i am your father
when it's actually no i am your father
right um
also the uh forrest gump the famous
forrest gump line
life is like a box of chocolates in the
movie he actually says life
was like a box of chocolates um
jaws i think there's one from jaws which
uh i think the big
the one everyone quotes is we're gonna
need a bigger boat but it's actually
you're going to need a bigger boat okay
um there was actually another
star wars it wasn't a line but and this
one kind of freaked me out a little bit
because c-3po right in the first movie
um and c-3p everybody thinks of him as
all gold right
yeah and i even had the action figure
when i was little and he's all gold
but i was looking up mandela effect
stuff on youtube
and they pointed they said no in the
first star wars movie a new hope
one of his legs from the knee down is
silver yeah
and i remember it being that way though
and i didn't remember that okay so when
i went
back and watched it i was like oh look
at that so that kind of weirded me out
yeah one of his shins was silver one of
his shins was as though he had
like a replacement it's like a
replacement part right but it wasn't
like that in empire right
i think they fixed it later on he also
had a dent in his forehead for a while
yeah i think at the end of new hope they
fixed that dent well now see i asked
i've asked about empire because i'm
pretty sure
no actually return of the jedi is what
i'm thinking of somebody posted a
picture from return of the jedi where um
c-3po was sitting on the throne in the
ewok village
and one of the legs was silver there too
it was
so i don't know if it actually was or if
somebody shopped that
or i don't know
yeah that one did kind of weird me out
um and also
they're um this is a funny one
a lot of people remember that there was
a painting of henry viii with a turkey
leg in his hand
like a famous painting yeah and there
was no no
but you know what i remember where that
came from where'd it come from that came
from
some ad or a commercial when i was a kid
that had that famous painting of him
that portrait of him but he had a turkey
remember he appeared and bewitched one
time with a turkey leg in his hand
remember that when uncle arthur had him
appear
what is with him and the turkey paul
lint there was no painting
of henry viii for the turkey leg okay i
think that came
it should have been though there should
have been i'm not saying that
there was no painting not you know
but i think that came from that came
from an ad or something like that
because i do remember that
turkey leg being a thing and um
you know there's other stuff too like
other celebrity deaths which you know
we've all experienced the kind of thing
where somebody dies and we're like in
that [ __ ] dead already
right yeah you know so there's all kind
of that mandela effect
yeah oh and this one this one is
actually kind of weird um for all of you
bible scholars out there
so you know how there's like a kind of a
popular
thing like the lion lying down with the
lamb or whatever and even
and if you look on google search there's
like a ton of pictures of it right
except that shit's not in there not in
the bible it's a wolf
lying down with the lamb okay okay
there's two quotes from isaiah
all right like there's a lion in there
but the lion and the lamb are not
together
okay so um so some people think their
bible got changed
okay at some point because they're like
why do all these people do
artwork of a little lying lion and a
lamb laying down it's not it's a wolf in
a lab
okay but uh so i thought that was a
little bit weird
and um and there's also there was also a
thing where
this one i don't know if this counts or
not but apparently there's this island
uh it's out by australia somewhere like
in the coral sea
called sandy island and it appeared on
maps up until about the 19th century
and then all of a sudden um they started
like
ships started going by and flying and
there's no island there
so it was a totally invented island so
they're not sure if there used to be an
island there
and then it sank or some [ __ ] i don't
know if there was a volcano
or if the original people who mapped it
like because it's been mapped more than
once okay so they don't know if the
original people that mapped it like saw
something else that wasn't an island
wait hold on this is off the coast of
what now
australia but far it's in the coral sea
all right so it's not near the the
coastline no no no it's far
could it be that someone mismapped it
and others copied it
i guess that's possible saying well
there must it must have been there
because it's on this because it's on
this map and they just were like too
late
are there any surviving copies of that
map with that island on it
as far as i know there are that's why
people are wondering where that island
went to
huh wow but like you said it might have
just that it might have been might have
been an error
yeah there's a lot more into that or
like i said there yeah it's called sandy
island there's a wikipedia
must have been a tiny island though yeah
i'm sure it wasn't really that big
like i said maybe it's sunk because of a
volcano that'd be weird who knows that
would be weird wouldn't it
yeah it's atlantis or it was a really
big sea monster
like the back of a really big sea
monster
it must have it must have been an error
in mapping yeah and then they just kept
copying that same error
yeah here's the thing here's or like you
said maybe something changed on the
seabed
yeah and it sank a few feet i think
that's not visible
than them than people like erasing an
island right okay now here's one that's
kind of
weird that this i don't know if this
counts either but this kind of wigged me
out
um so when i was a kid or teenager
one of my favorite shows was that
british uh sitcom
the young ones yeah from the 80s
and i noticed that someone had posted a
youtube video
under mandela effect about the young
ones and i said oh i got to see this
because i've seen all the episodes like
a million times
and i was like so i would know right
but here's the weird thing now it says
in this video
that there was because you know on the
young ones there were four
housemates right it was rick mike
neal and vivian now this person said no
there's a fifth one
but you never see his face because his
hair is always hanging over his face and
he's always like in the background
and he's never mentioned he's never
referred to and i was like this [ __ ]
i never saw that
right and like i looked at the stills
that this person had posted on the video
and i was like they photoshopped that
come on i don't remember that
so then i went back and watched the
original shows again
and that guy is in there yeah he showed
it to me it's weird it's hard to see
though well a couple of them a couple of
them he's like kind of in the background
are kind of off to the side
but one of them he's like he's kind of
in the so the fifth order
there's a fifth one they hid the whole
time pretty much okay
and actually it's weird because ben
elton who was
like one of the creators of the show he
apparently said he
had no [ __ ] idea what they were
talking about there were only four
people right
but one of the other writers or
producers or whatever
said that oh yeah well we used to put
funny [ __ ] in the background
um you know just for shits and giggles
yeah and
we you know he's like we wanna we were
gonna put this guy in the background and
like just never have anyone talk to him
or refer to him or anything and he never
talks or moves
and you know just never mentioned he's
like but we forgot to do it
in every episode so actually so if you
look
some of the episodes happen so some of
the he's definitely in uh the one called
bomb
he's kind of sitting in the living room
like kind of on the floor
and he's in the one uh he's in the one
called
oil i think he's like in the back corner
and he's in um i think the one is called
interesting which is weird because this
one he's really
obvious like there's a shot of the
staircase and then this old man like
comes out of the closet or whatever
and the guy is like sitting right there
like in the foreground
like but you can't see this but he looks
like cousin it kind of like has his hair
just over his face
and then he has this kind of black you
know
poncho kind of thing on and he's sitting
right there like i got pictures of it
that's not paranormal though no no it's
just it's just weird that
you didn't notice it that i never
noticed it and you think that i would
have noticed
i mean some of them it's probably easy
to avoid now wasn't there
wasn't there one about uh the chinese
tank
that's right a lot of people um the
tiananmen square like the famous photo
of the guy standing in front of the tank
apparently a lot of people have a really
vivid memory of him getting
run over by the tank yeah i never did i
never had that memory which he did not
right actually and actually if you go
back and watch the whole video
he stands in front of the tank the tank
stops he climbs up on the tank
and talks to the guy in the tank yeah
and then he gets back down and then the
tank kind of goes off to the side and
stops again
and then he just kind of stands there
and then eventually
he walks up he just kind of wanders off
yeah like other people come and he
wanders off
so you know that guy is fine he didn't
get run over but apparently a lot of
people have really vivid
memories of the guy getting run over no
he didn't get run over he did not get
run over
so like i said some people have
some weird theories about
why this is and
what i mean i don't think there's
anything paranormal to this
wasn't there one about the movies jaws i
already said that are you okay
okay yeah no no not not the jaws i'm
talking about that the james bond movie
with the guy jaws
oh my god thank you for reminding me
okay um that was from what movie was it
from moonraker moonraker right moonraker
okay so the guy richard keel that played
jaws there's a famous scene
of him and then this girl comes up she's
got little
she's got braids right he was in a he
was in a uh a cable car yeah europe did
the cable car fall
i think it did i think the cable car
fell and he survived the crash
right when he climbed out there was a a
little chick there with
braids in her hair and uh glasses she
was like a nerdy chick and she smiles at
him and they walk off
right and evidently that becomes his
girlfriend right
but it didn't really make sense everyone
remembers her
having braces having braces you can
probably tell it better than me
yeah um here's the thing and
actually this was parodied a lot like
after moonraker came out
so apparently there's this big famous
scene of richard keel
as jaws and you know he has those metal
teeth smiling
and then the nerdy girl smiling back at
him
and her having braces but if you watch
the movie now
she does not have braces right and there
are no pictures of her with braces and i
think i remember
her having braces see everyone does
right like this one
this one i can't really have an opinion
on because i saw moonraker so long ago
that i didn't remember it
the scene only made sense if she had
break and see this
this was kind of the weirdest example
for me because when i watch the scene on
youtube
like yeah it doesn't make any sense it's
just it's just a little cute girl
smiling at this guy with metal teeth
yeah and and it was weird because later
like even in foreign countries and [ __ ]
there was i think was it finland or
somewhere like that like did a
commercial
where they parodied that like with the
girl with braces like smiling
and why would they do that and that was
like a long time ago like nearer to
where
to when moonraker came out now why would
they do that if she didn't really have
braces now is everyone just
remembering braces when there weren't
any i don't know
or were they removed later no they
weren't removed later no or
what i think it was i think was
suggestion
maybe he smiled and they were so he had
silver teeth and then she smiled and she
was a nerd
she didn't have silver teeth but it
somehow it was
it was suggested that she did yeah and
that's what you saw
kind of like something a mentalist would
do that's pretty weird though
like the power of suggestion
i think i remember that scene and i
think i remember her having braces
i can picture her she kind of looked
like wendy from uh from wendy's
you know yeah yeah that is pippi
longstocking kind of yeah
yeah she had like little braids like she
was cute but she was like a nerdy
yeah like she had a little kid she's
probably in her 20s yeah she wasn't
little right
but um but like you said that was
probably that's the weirdest one because
that scene doesn't really make any sense
if she doesn't have braces i mean it's
funnier
with braces because you'd be like hey i
have metal teeth you have middle teeth i
guess it was just the power suggestion
and it seemed to
it seemed to be that everyone else got
that same suggestion yes when they
parroted it they put braces they put
braces on her
and everyone remembers her having braces
and she did
and she didn't but like you said it
doesn't make any sense but she doesn't
have braces to me
because they don't even talk to each
other they just smile at each other and
then he's like hey and then they take
you know they hold hands and like walk
off into the sunset or whatever
yeah and you know i don't know but that
doesn't that doesn't make any sense but
um
so so what do you think it's here's the
weird thing
like i don't think there's anything
particularly paranormal going on but
it's still
really fascinating to me how people's
memories can go
awry in exactly the same way like so
many people's memories
yeah that's a pretty freaky kind of
thing right
i mean i i don't that's kind of a cool
idea that somehow the past can change a
little bit
yeah you know i mean as if it's as if
the past isn't fixed
but you got to come up with some better
examples than what they're given
yeah it's weird because it never seems
to be it's never anything major
no not really and you would think though
that even something small had it changed
in the past could have big ramifications
like
for instance let's say
in that scene from moonraker the girl
smiled and she did have braces
right okay and there was braces
originally in that scene
if that became popular enough let's say
that actress then went on to make
commercials
of her with braces okay oh i see that
let's say if those commercials okay
brought her to stardom and she ended up
becoming a superstar
and then she ends up giving birth to
some children that end up being
you know superstar children or something
so you know what i mean
a small thing could have big
ramifications like a butterfly effect so
i don't think
i don't think little things in the past
are changing doesn't make sense
it would impact too much yeah on the
present
yeah and like you said i mean some
people are saying oh it's like all
people from
alternate time streams are remembering
things wrong and stuff like that
and like i said going back to the
berenstain bears thing
like i said all y'all [ __ ] from get
out of my time stream that just remember
with an e because it never had an e it
was always an a
yeah and i you know why i remember that
because it should have an e
because that's a more common i mean
s-t-e-i-n is a much more common
uh you know name ending than stain who
the [ __ ] is baron staying with what kind
of name is that right
you remembered it that way well i
remembered it because it was unusual
right and see i think what's happening
is that people
are remembering it as berenstein because
that's the more common
iteration of that name right but i
remembered it because it was weird
and it's always something that you
remember from a long time ago yeah and
that's proof that it's your memory
because there were little things that i
remembered happening when i was a kid
went back and looked at it like saying a
movie or a video
and it didn't remember it didn't happen
the way i remembered it no and i have
the same thing happen too it's like i
see movies much later and i was like
you know stuff happened in there that i
remember i remembered it wrong or i'm
mixing up two different movies
right or you know some kind of thing
like that
but um the you know the weird thing i
i was kind of weirded out by a couple of
them like i did not remember
uh c-3po having one silver lag i
remember that but see
the reason i didn't remember that is one
because i had the toy and the toy was
all gold
right and two like you wouldn't really
notice it
like most of the time he was walking
around in the desert it was subtle and
the sand would kind of reflect
on the thing and kind of make them all
look gold so you wouldn't really be you
know you're not really looking for it
one way to prove prove it is go back go
back and listen to
a song that you used to think was really
cool but you haven't heard it in a long
time
yeah something that you remember from
the 80s not one of your favorite songs
but one of the ones that you didn't
really
listen to that much right from an
obscure band it's going to sound
different than you remember oh yeah
and because i think uh it's not gonna be
as cool as you remembered it
no no some things are but not very many
things i'm sad to say
and actually um i was watching a ted
talk the other day by
elizabeth loftus who's kind of uh she
works a lot in
memory and stuff like that and she's
saying that
memory is not it's you know obviously
it's not like a recording they can just
play back it's actually constructive
when you
when you remember something you're not
remembering the actual thing you're
remembering your last
memory of it right and the farther away
you get from the more
reconstructive that memory becomes the
more [ __ ] you add on to it
you know so that's the thing it's like i
kind of feel like
like i said most of these are pretty
minor
and another one that people remember and
this
this one is stupid because i've never
met anyone who ever remembered this
apparently there are a large percentage
of people who think that there are 51 or
52
states well there are 52 cards
there are 52 cards yeah well see some
people think i don't know it and i think
it's because they have a misperception
one that there were 50 states before
alaska and hawaii got added
right um if they think they're 51 maybe
they think puerto rico counts or they're
gonna make
puerto rico one or something like that
but then i was kind of like
didn't they ever learn that song 50
nifty united states
i never learned that song i learned it
in elementary school
and that is why to this day i can still
remember all the state names in
alphabetical order
because that's how that song goes and so
i don't know why anyone would think they
were
i mean you know i could see if you're
from another country or something like
that you know fair enough
but uh the mandela effect's interesting
but i just think
it is an interesting yeah it's
interesting but um
we need more evidence you need more
evidence i'm not totally convinced on it
it is just interesting though
i just think those are tricks tricks of
the memory and suggestion
another thing and actually i talked to
you about this one on saturday
a lot of people um remember chick-fil-a
as spelled c-h-i-c-f-i-l-a
uh now it's actually now
here's the weird thing i remembered it
being spelled c-h-i-k
that's how i remember and no it's not
because of the cows like the misspelled
cows because i remember being a kid
and being pissed off because it wasn't
spelled correctly
and you know yeah they had the cows
later on with the misspelled signs and
that was like a big thing and i can see
how
maybe you would think but no because i
remember being a kid and being mad that
it was spelled with just a k
and i said it should be c-h-i-c-k
but we were driving by a billboard
for chick-fil-a just this saturday and
it is c-h-i-c-k it's spelled correctly
it is and i was like when did that
happen i don't know
i remembered it just i hadn't remembered
being okay
i didn't pay attention and even when i
did a google search because i said maybe
it was just a k and then everybody
complained like i did like why is it
spelled wrong i said okay we're going to
spell it right
but even when i did a google search and
i put c-h-i-k fully they were like did
you mean c-h-i-c-k
you dumb ass and i was like oh i guess
they did spell it right the whole time
i guess they did spell it right the
whole time but um
so you know whatever i know some people
think and it's kind of cool to
speculate that it might be a glitch in
the matrix or
alternate time streams or something like
that but i don't know i just you know
it'd be different if people were
remembering like wars and [ __ ] that
didn't happen or like some people
remember wars and other people didn't
remember wars
but uh it's never anything like that
it's always like just minor
entertainment [ __ ] right mostly like
from from people's childhoods
yeah yeah yeah it's it's it's
interesting it's just something you got
to keep an eye on you know i'm gonna
just gotta keep an eye on that and until
they come up with something better
i'm just gonna say no oh and did you
did you remember curious george having a
tail
no i don't think curious george had a
tail did he okay no yeah
a lot of people remember him having a
tail but and and uh all the curious
george costumes they make have a tail
but i said well the only reason that the
costume has a tail is because if it
didn't have a tail it would look like a
bear
okay okay although you'd think that he
would have a tail because he's a monkey
he's not a chimpanzee right
what kind of monkeys i thought he was a
chimpanzee or maybe he is supposed to be
a champion
they call him a monkey chimpanzee's an
ape though whatever that's i'm being
pedantic
all right so uh it's almost coming up on
the half hour mark so i guess we're
gonna
stop and take a break and then we will
come back and talk about our second
topic which is super creepy
so we'll be back in just a minute i
would like to take a second
and thank subculture corsets and
clothing for sponsoring project i radio
and my show while listening to my
podcast please take a second and visit
their website at
dot www.subculturecorsets.com they carry
a wide selection of corsets rockabilly
gothic steampunk and pin-up clothing
shoes and accessories
again their website is
subculturecorsets.com or if you're in
the jacksonville florida area stop by
their store in the avenues mall
and if you like to save money use the
discount code 13 o'clock
when checking out and save 10 off your
entire order
by the way if you're a curvy girl
subculture did not forget about you
they carry size 4 to 4x and guys they
have men's clothing and shoes as well
so go shop at subculturecorsets.com now
and use the discount code
13 o'clock for a 10 discount
okay and we're back now since we're
doing um kind of a weird memory kind of
theme
i wanted to do something about like
a creepy reincarnation case yeah you
told me a little bit about this one i've
never heard this before
yeah i had neither but i actually kind
of looked it up now the reason i
wanted to do this was because um if
you'll remember on our first episode
um we talked about the entity which was
uh
written the book was written by frank
defilitta now frank defolita also wrote
a book called audrey rose
and i had actually thought that audrey
rose was based on an actual
reincarnation case but it's not
really um he actually just got the idea
because
apparently his six-year-old son one day
could play the piano when he hadn't been
able to before
weird i didn't know that's what he says
okay
that's what he claims anyway but um so
that kind of gave him the idea and then
he started talking to
i think he started talking to this guy
who in the 60s was like a big
advocate of reincarnation studies
and did like a lot of case studies of it
and stuff like that um his name's
ian stevenson dr ian stevenson i think
and uh this was one of the cases
that they're all kind of creepy but this
one kind of uh creeped me the hell out
okay but uh what it is
it was the okay it was 1957 and it was
england and there were this there was
this family and they lived in this
town i think it's called hexam yeah in
northumberland
and they were john pollock and his wife
now they had two daughters joanna was 11
and jacqueline was six in may of 1957
the two little girls and their little
friend who was a little boy
they were walking to church and they all
three of them got hit by a car
and they all died okay right
so you know obviously very horrible and
very scary
and here was the weird thing though
now john pollock the dad he was a devout
catholic
um but he kind of believed in
reincarnation now his wife got pregnant
about a year after
their daughters died and um
you know the gynecologist said it was
this it was just a single
baby okay but the dad insisted
that it was going to be twin girls and
that their two daughters
were going to be reincarnated
and uh in october of nineteen insisted
this
yeah okay based on what he had a feeling
he just had a feeling okay
he had a feeling um and the doctor said
no it's just one kid
all right but in october 1958 his wife
gave his birth and it was indeed
twin girls okay weird so
i'm gonna sit back here and vape and
have you tell me
now here was the weird thing the twins
were um monozygotic meaning
you know they both came from one egg
okay
but one of them had
one she had a birthmark on her forehead
that corresponded
to a scar that one of the dead daughters
had
okay like one of the dead daughters i
think the older one had a scar on her
forehead from where she fell off her
bicycle
okay and one of the babies had a
birthmark on her forehead that kind of
corresponded like a white spot
all right she also had a birthmark on
her hip
just like the dead girl
now um so here was the thing
there was there was also like a bunch of
other weird [ __ ] that happened like
the the babies were not raised um
where you know where they had been
living when the
when the daughters died the original
daughters died they moved away when the
twins were still babies hold on i'm
confused
so the the new set of twins are being
raised in a different location
yeah they they moved when they were
still babies okay
to a different town all right now when
the twins were four years old
the parents took the twins back to the
town that they
had originally lived in you know when
their daughters died
when the daughters died okay but these
these little girls had never been there
they had been there but only very little
only when they were like until they were
like three months or six months or
something like that okay
and yet when they drove into
the town hexam where they were from
originally
the twins insisted that they wanted to
go to this particular park
and they described the park they
described landmarks
they knew where the their old house was
without having to be told they knew
where everything was in the town
so they had all the landmarks they knew
where everything was yeah okay
and they knew the name of the park they
wanted to go to they left there at six
months of age
something like that they were still
babies yeah they could have known they
were still babies
um so the original daughters
had lived there as that was that the
original daughters had was there
that's where the that's where the
original daughters had been killed okay
in uh hexam was the original town then
they moved to another town later called
whitley bay
all right so but when they went back
and um also
they now apparently the parents had
never told the twins
about the dead daughters okay um they
had all their stuff put away like in the
attic or whatever
and they never brought it out they never
talked about them or anything like that
and yet
still the the twins would ask for
particular
toys that the dead daughters had had
all right and when these toys were
brought out
they knew the names of all the dolls and
the stuffed animals and all that kind of
stuff that the dead daughters had had
okay um there was also and this was
the creepiest thing to me this is pretty
[ __ ] creepy
but um there was also a thing where
the two little girls would because they
said their personalities were kind of
similar to
uh to the original daughters also but
they said that the two little girls
would kind of play this weird game
where the where one of them would lay
with her head in the other one's lap
and then the one whose lap the girl was
in
she would say you're bleeding out your
eyes that's where the car hit you
weird like she would say [ __ ] like and
they didn't know that of the priorities
evidently now they didn't know
their other sisters no evidently not
because it was i mean they were born
you know almost two years after after it
happened after it had happened
okay and the weirdest thing too was when
they were about four or five
they were playing outside and their mom
like heard them screaming or something
like that and she went out there
and they were like clutching each other
and screaming
there was a car idling it wasn't moving
but it was on and it was idling and the
headlights were on
and they kept saying the car is going to
get us the car is going to get us
and they were like wigging out weird now
the weirdest thing is that that incident
like them thinking the car was gonna get
them
that was like the last thing they said
after they turned five
they no longer remembered anything they
no longer
you know apparently had any kind of
connection
weird with with their um oh so
you know i think the doctor that worked
on this his theory was that
once kids turned five you know they
no longer had access to this other world
or these other memories or whatever
because it seems like once they got to
the age of five they no longer said
anything about past lives
what's the name of this case does it
have the pollock twins it's just
generally called the pollock twins yeah
could it have been
have could could it have excuse me could
it have
had anything to do with epigenetics
you know that's a good question there
could be some kind of maybe there was
some kind of
weird well instead of inheriting
the memories from the sisters that would
have been impossible
what if they inherited the memories from
the traumatized
mother hmm
that they were remembering the the
mother's memories
that they were it was passed down
through her dna
you know epigenetics is you know right
you might be able to explain it better
than me but it's like
they say that mothers who experience
certain traumas while they're
around the pregnancy time can pass those
that those traumas on to the child
right there's evidently some some
scientific
evidence to back this up people that
survived say like 9 11.
the kids when they came out they had uh
higher levels of stress
and they were more i had heard that yeah
i wonder did they actually i should
actually
look this up one of these days because
animals inherit memory
true why can't children inherit a
certain amount of memory and then when
they get old enough
the brain takes over and they're alone
they don't they need it anymore they
don't need inherited memories
isn't that interesting now i wonder if i
actually think and i don't know if you
told me this or some
or if i read this somewhere else but
when you said about 9 11 i
did i do remember reading that some
people said that not only were
the kids have higher stress and things
like that but they also had like
nightmares about
planes planes and fires and things
falling on them and
yeah it does it wouldn't surprise me if
if you know humans do inherit
certain amounts of memories because when
i was a little kid i remember
things that my dad said
had happened to my granddad about
falling over in a tractor
my dad and his dad fell over in a
tractor one time yeah
and when i was about that age four or
five i asked my dad you remember the
time we fell over in the tractor
oh that's spooky yeah and he's like no
we never fell over in a tractor
and i said yeah we fell over in a
tractor but we were all right
and i can remember remembering it but
it's just a weird way of
you know i can't really explain it about
riding along in a tractor and the
tractor hitting in a
hitting a uh what do you call it like a
ditch
and it turned it over on its side and we
fell out we laughed
it wasn't a real big tractor it was a
smaller tractor
and evidently that happened to my
granddad and my dad it never happened to
me
that's pretty awesome yeah so maybe i
just
inherited that through my dad maybe so
maybe maybe those were my dad's memories
yeah not my grandfather's memories
wouldn't that be something that people
i mean that would explain like a lot of
this kind of weird because there's also
the case that i'm looking at it right
now
there's also the case of a little kid
named gus taylor
who claimed this he's like the kid who
was his own grandpa
similar kind of thing like he had
memories of his grandpa and he kept
saying he was his grandpa
grandpa auggie and uh
he said when he was um he when he was 18
months old and he was still wearing
diapers
his dad was changing his diapers and the
baby said
i used to change your diapers yeah like
he was his grandpa
like he was his father yeah evidently i
used to say things like that too
my dad was trying to get the uh get the
keys in the door and i was in the
stroller and i went god damn son of a
[ __ ]
and i was a little kid in a stroller and
my dad looked at me because my dad used
to say the same thing
you know and my mother was like where
did you hear that from you know
there's i'm sorry but there's like
nothing funnier than kids swearing yeah
god has some of it he couldn't get the
keys in the door it's dark
that's awesome yeah now i you know i do
have to say
like i don't know like actually i'm kind
of glad that you brought up that
epigenetics thing about like memories
somehow being transferred through dna
because i think that's actually more
likely than this kind of like soul
reincarnating and i think it's more
likely
yeah because it happens in other animals
why wouldn't it happen in humans right
we're animals
yeah that's kind of again and maybe it
was just a temporary memory that you
inherit
for survival reasons you know and maybe
it's kind of a
vestigial from other ancestors that we
have right and then you get to a certain
age and those memories
are get superseded yeah by your own
memories
yeah now i'm not saying that because
look there are whole websites
of kids saying creepy [ __ ]
yeah what kids kids say and do crazy
they say creepy [ __ ]
all the time they say random [ __ ] but
you know what if some of that [ __ ] is
true what if some of these kids like
what if your kid came to you and said
something like that's how i died and i
saw blah blah blah
you know they do say [ __ ] like that well
there was some kid that evidently
uh he knew everything about world war a
world war
ii aircraft that's right remember that
james
lininger i think his name is yeah he was
yeah and that was a good case
and then he claimed to be a certain guy
who died in
uh world war ii that's right he was a
fighter pilot yeah off of an aircraft
carrier yeah
and he was a little kid yeah and he knew
everything about that aircraft carrier
and the aircraft
uh well seemingly everything you know we
didn't interview the kid
and and for somehow um what'd they do
the james lenninger is that his name
yeah what does it say there um it says
yeah
yeah because these were kind of like
famous cases so apparently when he was a
little kid
he knew the name of the pilot that he
used to be
okay which was uh james houston jr he
knew the name of the ship
that he had served on um he knew the
name of his co-pilot um
and he knew that he had been shot down
at iwo jima
okay and there's no way he could have
known this as a little he was a little
kid
yeah right yeah yeah apparently he was
he was a little kid and
um did they reunite him with some of his
friends from the air
from from uh from from the air i think
they did yeah
and he knew their names yeah he didn't
even have to he didn't even
he goes oh i remember i know him and
they would tell his name i know that guy
yeah
yeah yeah weird how old was he um well
let's see
eight nine something maybe i think he
actually i think he was younger younger
i think he might have been younger than
that but um there was also another case
like
uh this kid named edward austrian
and um he had like all these weird
phobias
about rain and also he um
he had a lot of throat problems wait
wait before we go on what
that kid uh the last one with the the
aircraft carrier kid
he wasn't related to that guy so that
couldn't have been had anything to do
with that
right that must be
that's a certain amount of evidence
towards towards actual reincarnation
that's true yeah i didn't know there was
no way he could have researched that
information because i mean the whole
thing with the pollock twins was that
i mean obviously their mother was
traumatized because her
kids had died i think that was
epigenetics yeah and um so maybe she
passed that on to them
but the the aircraft carrier the
airplane kid i don't
that couldn't have been epigenetic yeah
i think that was just a random kiss it
was either
real it was either real reincarnation or
a hoax
an elaborate hoax one of the two yeah
which you know there's always that
possibility yeah but um
and you know they're studying that's
another thing one you know kids say
creepy [ __ ]
two kids pick up a lot more than people
think they do
and can parrot it back like so
i don't know like how have you ever
known the name of an obscure fighter
pilot that's true
on a air on an aircraft carrier knowing
exactly what kind of plane that he flew
and what battle he got killed yeah see
that's kind of
that's a stretch stuff like that you
would you'd be hard-pressed to find that
even with internet access and i think he
was doing that before
well yeah that was a long time ago that
was a long time ago
but um yeah so there was this other kid
edward austrian who's also like a pretty
famous uh reincarnation case
um so he had like a lot of throat
problems all the time
and um he said he called his throat
problems
his shot or that's where i got shot okay
right
and um so when he was four
he developed a cyst in his throat and he
had to go get it uh removed
and he said that like he told his mom
that when he was 18 he was a soldier
and he had been in the trenches and he
was shot in the throat
now after he told his mom that the cyst
in his throat disappeared like when he
was four or five years old
weird so you know they don't know and
like i said this is another random kid
he couldn't but he couldn't name a name
i don't think well like this is just
kind of a little paragraph here so i'm
not really sure if he knew the guy's
name i mean you know yeah
that could just be a kid saying another
possibility is that
instead of reincarnation maybe they're
somehow psychically accessing like
akashic records and
they call it a caching right yeah some
kind of something you know recorded in a
parallel dimension maybe some kind of
quantum information maybe
yeah i wonder can like every kid do it
maybe it's like channeling
yeah i don't know i wonder can every kid
do it with most people don't notice
because kids don't like i said they're i
can remember me as a little kid you're
almost
in a pair in a altered state of
consciousness constantly
yeah you're kind of in a in a dream
world slash
the animal world yeah because your brain
isn't functioning the same way as an
adult does
yeah you'd see things and that kind of
have a dream like quality sometimes
yeah do you remember that yeah well kind
of because it was hard to tell sometimes
what was imagination what wasn't
yeah it's weird i don't depend on how
young you were i'm talking about when i
was like three
four you know you're i don't really
remember like a lot of my childhood
which kind of disturbs me a little bit
really like i kind of remember kind of
random things
but for some reason i just don't
remember a lot of it and and
the parts of it i do remember i know
this is going to sound weird but
the parts that i do remember i almost
think that like i'm the only one that
experienced that so whenever like i'm
talking to
any of my siblings or anything and if
one of my siblings will bring up
something that i remember from being a
kid i'm like super freaked out like you
remember that too
yeah like i thought it was just me or it
was just i don't know why that is
i can remember being in a stroller out
in california going to sea world
seeing uh killer whales and this
huge killer whales jumping up out of the
pool yeah
and uh i remember being real close to
him i couldn't have been as
close to them as i remembered it yeah
but i mean probably because you were so
little and they were so big
but what was weird is that you know i
was still in a stroller i could barely
talk
and i remember understanding what a
killer whale was that it was a big
fish you know what a fish of course you
know it was a huge aquatic thing i i
i remember understanding that yeah
that's a big
monster going on yeah it could eat black
and white yeah
eat you like you were just a little i
thought it was awesome you know they
were pretty awesome i thought it was
awesome so a little kid can
appreciate things it's weird because you
know what one of the only things i
remember from my childhood is
my parents taking me to seaworld here in
florida really and i had one of those
like little you know the strollers they
had that looked like little whales or
fish or whatever the [ __ ] they were
supposed to be
yeah and uh yeah i could have only been
two or three
right i remember i dropped my binky that
day
it felt yeah it fell yeah and you know
how you know you know when you're in the
stroller and your feet are down on that
little
it's like a little wire grid yeah it
fell and it went down through those
through through the wire grid and each
my mom kept pushing me oh no i was going
there goes there
ghosts no no little did i know
i when i got older i said mom remember
the time i dropped my binky
she goes oh yeah we i remember that he
goes i saw you drop it
then i just kept all walking because you
were getting too old for a baby
so that was how i broke it so she left
yeah she says no more binky for him he
doesn't need a binky
oh my gosh that was danny binky's harsh
yeah it was just how you did things you
know
i was too old for a binky eye evidently
i was maybe two three
yeah in those days i guess you don't get
too old because you know back in those
days
binky was lost by just naturals
by natural means i dropped it and that
was it
did they did they tell you that you
couldn't uh that if you did that too
long that you would have bought teeth
i don't remember yeah see that's that's
what my grandma is used to i don't
remember but see i don't i didn't have a
boy we call it a pacifier but um
yeah i call it you weirdo
that's how they did it back then man
dropped it and that's it there goes no
no my binky
but what was funny is that i remember my
mom said that i'd forgotten all about it
back
uh 20 minutes later i'd forgotten all
about it well yeah but you still
i remembered it but you know i remember
it happening but she said that i forgot
all about vicki's 20 minutes later
that's so funny
never never did
come on this is perfect we're doing
paranormal weird stuff we're talking
about binkies
okay well you know we're talking about
memories of the memories yeah it's
memory thing it's a memory show
but so um
all right so basically i mean i don't
know
we're like i said we're talking about
pollock twins apparently they grew up
and
uh they were quite normal afterward
um i guess they're still alive but
i don't know it's just i don't know that
creeps me out the thing that creeps me
out the most
is that [ __ ] blood coming out of her
eyes thing
yeah but little kids say weird stuff you
know what i mean i used to i we used to
say weird stuff like that all the time
that's true and yeah and adults read
into it because they moralize everything
when you're a little kid you don't have
a moral system like that
yeah you're like a cat or a dog or a
monkey
yeah you know you're kind of animalistic
so yeah blood yeah we're going to eat
him
i'm going to eat him you know yeah we
said
we just we used to joke around you know
me my little little buddies yeah we're
going to eat you
you know you know that would terrify
adults you know well nowadays they'd be
like right now there's gonna be a cereal
cake yeah yeah it could be a serial
killer
which i guess well here's the shitty
thing about that is like every now and
then
they do grow up to be a singer you don't
know you don't know
yeah it's funny like which one it's to
be you don't know which one it's going
to be
but um i don't know so
uh do do you have anything else you
would like to add about reincarnate do
you think you were a reincarnation of
anybody
well according according to my parents
you know
if i were possibly a reincarnation of
anybody who'd been my grandfather
yeah but no i think it was epigenetics i
do remember some things
that had my grandfather in and i never
met him right you know he died before i
was born
but i think i may have inherited some
memories from my dad
yeah but like i said they they mostly
kind of fade away as you get older
yeah i remember the tractor but i'd
never seen a tractor i'd ever ridden a
tractor at the time i was saying that
i could vaguely remember the tractor i
think i even remember what color it was
i think it was kind of blue
yeah it looked like something out of the
60s or 50s you know like just pressed
steel construction
kind of yeah top or steel construction
you know it was it wasn't a modern
tractor i remember it
and i remember falling over and i
remember
being a little kid or i don't remember
if i was the little kid or if i was the
adult so that's the thing
yeah it's it's just weird
i think it was just some kind of
inherited memory through my dad yeah
yeah man wouldn't that be something see
that's a
that kind of bothers me now i kind of
wish that i like remembered weird [ __ ]
like that from my childhood and like i
said i can't really remember hardly
anything the only reason why i
remember it is because my parents kept
reminding me of of it right that i had
said that and i'm gonna go yeah i
remember that
as i was you know my mother asked me
again do you remember this that and i
said yeah i remember
saying that huh you know there's that
kind of stuff so you never really lost
the memory because they kept reminding
me because they kept reminding me of it
had they not reminded me of it but i
would have forgotten it
yeah i only remember stuff that they
took pictures of okay
you know that's that's the only reason i
remember that seaworld thing is because
they took a picture of me in the little
i was a normal i was an only child so i
would say things you know and it would
trip my mom out and she would remember
it you know how when
i guess when you have when you have a
mother who's only had one child
they think the child is strange i guess
if the child does sometimes well yeah
because that's like your first
that's their first experience so that's
your first experience as a mom say
remember
everything yeah yeah i mean had i had
siblings
they probably would have said crazy
stuff too and it wouldn't have been made
into a big deal she probably
kept questioning them but she questioned
me over and over again she questioned me
weird about weird [ __ ]
like you know she'd give me a lifesaver
lollipop you know
yeah and uh and i'd eat it and she goes
okay it's gone now but where'd the hole
go you know oh my god my grandpa used to
say yeah where'd the whole go you know
but i was like i was little you know i
was like five i was just like there
can't be a hole without a
thing on the side because you finally
figured that one out that took me a
couple times to figure that one out
so she like blew your mind she blew my
mind what yeah it was it was
yeah yeah yeah now you're like laying
awake in your crib going where did the
hole go where is it
actually i was in a car seat in the car
i was in a car seat next to her
drive to san diego and i'd look out the
window with you know candy and stuff
he goes yeah it's gone but where'd the
hole go where's the hole you you know
what since we're talking about memories
you need to tell the story about how you
got drunk when you were five in the yard
oh
yeah me and two my buddies you know they
were the same age as we
were probably about six five six
we grabbed a big old one gallon jug of
that annie green springs wine
because our moms were making wine
coolers out of that this is out in
california back in the 70s where you
couldn't buy a pre-made wine cooler you
just
got some cheap wine and you mixed it
with seven up that was your wine cooler
well they liked it so we figured it must
be good there wasn't it wasn't you know
they weren't around
all three of us grabbed that one big got
one gallon glass jug and we were out in
the front yard
just drink just down in that and cars
were going by
yeah and they were beeping their horns
they were loving it we were like giving
them a thumbs up yeah
yeah all three of us trying to drink
that big old jug
didn't last long though you know we
probably between the three of us maybe
drank uh about four cups of it but that
you know we were hammered yeah
we were hammered we had cause you were
little that's the way it was back in the
70s though yeah now there would have
been a lawsuit today but they left yeah
they take your kids away yeah but you
know back in the we were hardcore we
were like feral kids back in the 70s
70s you know that that's that made you
grow up to be a man i mean we should we
would go down to that we would go down
to the flood control system in
california
you know they showed it in the movie
greece you know it looked like a big uh
they filmed terminator there yeah it's
like a it's like a big storm drain it's
got a little
river down the middle and big concrete
slopes that go up the side
you know we used to go there we used to
hang out there there wasn't far from my
house those were everywhere out in
california
and uh man we would make torches and
steal gasoline from from the garage from
our dad's garage make torches and go
down into those
tunnels because we saw that 50s movie
them you know about the giant ants about
the giant ants yeah and the giant ants
were in there well you had to take care
of that
yeah so we'd go in there you know with
torches and flashlights
and we were young we were seven eight
yeah
you know kids don't grow up that way now
but you know this is in the age of evil
knievel man we all wanted to be
well yeah in the 70s and i mean in the
70s and early 80s i mean [ __ ] me and my
little brother we used to just run
around in the woods and blow stuff up i
would put my dad's motorcycle helmet on
and tie a beach towel around my neck
like a cape
and put my mom's dish gloves on you know
big yellow disc gloves
big rubber dish clubs and jump off of
top of the roof of the house because i
thought i was evil and evil
we all wanted to be daredevils well yeah
yeah it was awesome
okay now now going back to your wine
story didn't your mom take you to the
hospital
after that no no no that's when i was
about two and i drank those uh
drink that big old bottle of aftershave
oh right right because it was pretty
it was green yeah it was great of course
and it smelled good so i drank that i
grabbed my dad's aftershave
it was aqua velva yeah i remember that
[ __ ] yeah it looked pretty
good the doctor said oh yeah he's
hammered now he'd be all right
send him back you know go back home oh
my god nowadays they'd be calling child
protective yes
i'd get into everything yeah if it was a
pretty color and it smelled good i'd
drank it
god i can't imagine i mean you know your
poor mother
just kidding yeah yeah you're uh
you're a little hellion that's right i
was i was a good kid
i was a good kid no i was kind of quiet
well until i got a little bit older this
show is going too long
all right anyway the show is going too
long look at the time
all right so uh we're done talking about
memories and [ __ ] now and
getting off topic getting off that's
okay yeah it's it's fun to
digress sometimes it's not that long
don't worry about it okay okay so um be
sure to tune in next week and
subscribe to our youtube channel 13
o'clock podcast follow us on twitter
like us on facebook yeah um etc and so
forth
just search 13 o'clock podcast and find
us and
that's the end of the show bye bye
you